the end game of The Fast and Furious
franchise is coming can Dom and his
family survive Let's Ride
almost as soon as F9 the fast Saga and
sporting theaters in 2021 fans wanted to
know what's next and more importantly
they wanted to know when the follow-up
and 10th installment on The Fast and
Furious franchise would arrive in
theaters Entertainment Weekly reported
in August 2021 that they're still
tentatively titled Fast and Furious 10
would start filming in January 2022. in
advance of a release date of April 7th
2023 a few months later Universal
changed course and pushed back the
release of the film now officially known
as fast 10 the film's release date was
officially changed to May 19 2023
according to the plot summary on the
film's official website fastx is the
beginning of the end game for the
franchise Dominic Toretto and his family
stare down what's perhaps their most
dangerous Endeavor yet back in Fast Five
double company took down drug kingpin
Anan Reyes 12 years have passed and his
revenge-minded son who witnessed his
father's end has spent the entire period
devising an elaborate and probably fatal
Revenge plot surviving and fighting back
will take the huge and ever-expanding
crew around the world from Rome to Los
Angeles to Portugal and even Antarctica
as this movie is supposed to start to
wrap up the series plenty of long unseen
characters heroic and villainous are
likely to return to take size in the
developing war and it seems that not
every character will make its Ultra fast
10 alive one of us might not come back
from this
but we have
director Louis letterier told Empire
there's a war Brewing it's coming to an
end and there's a race to the Finish
there will be some tremendous casualties
he also added that the movie promises to
be so exciting that it's suggested in
the title he pronounces fast X as fast
10 like Fast turn your seat belts
family is extremely underpately
important to the Fast and Furious
franchise some expect plenty of familiar
faces to return to the series when it
arrives in theaters in May 2023 among
the returning cast members of Vin Diesel
as Dominic Toretto Jordana Brewster as
Mia torretto Tyrese Gibson as Roman
Michelle Rodriguez as Letty Ortiz sung
Kangaskhan Charlize Theron a cipher
hello mirinus Queenie John Cena as Jacob
Natalie Emanuel as Ramsay Chris Ludacris
Bridges as tej Michael Rooker as buddy
and Jason Statham as villain turned hero
Deckard Shaw new additions that already
ridiculously packed casts include
richest star Alan Richardson Oscar
winners Brie Larson and Rita Mourinho
Portuguese film star Daniela melchio and
beloved Action Hero and Aquaman himself
Jason Momoa as Dante Reyes the 10th
official entry in the Fast and Furious
saga will bear the creative thumbprint
of a director new to the franchise
Justin lenu Helm 2009's Fast and Furious
2011's Fast 5 2013's Fast and Furious 6
and 2021's F9 the fast Saga left the
directorial duties this time to Lewis
the terrier experience in the
eye-popping action movie milieu the
terrier directed fast 10 co-star Jason
Statham and the transporter and its
sequels as well as the 2008 MCU entry
The Incredible Hulk a 2010 remake of
Clash of the Titans and all 10 episodes
of Netflix's The Dark Crystal age of
resistance Lynn didn't entirely leave
The Fast and Furious family however he
collaborated on the fast 10 screenplay
with Daniel Casey a repairing of the
team who wrote the script for F9 the
fast Saga that film story came from the
mind of writer Alfredo Botello and he
similarly contributed the plot outline
for fast 10. after 10 Mainline films a
franchise is coming to a close versus
the trailers for fast suggests the
latest outing is only the beginning of
the end fast 10 May Mark the end of Fast
and Furious as we know it but it's only
the first part of the story after
previous reports a fast 10 will conclude
the series variety announced that the
fast Saga would end with a two-part
finale one that will reclaim the
franchise's street racing route though
we don't yet know the title or the
release date for the final installment
which will Mark Vin Diesel's 10th board
trail of Dom Toretto after skipping out
on 2 Fast 2 Furious we do know that the
Fast and Furious team is working hard to
develop a rewarding conclusion when
speaking with variety diesel further
explained the decision to end the
franchise with the 11th feature by
comparing the series to J.R.R tolkien's
the Lord of the Rings there's a reason
Tolkien stopped writing after a while
because it's so hard to continue
mythologies the longer this franchise
which went to outer space in F9 goes on
the harder it is to keep it grounded and
interesting he is hoping f11 finishes in
first
like many of the more recent Fast and
Furious pictures the cast and crew of
fast 10 find themselves traveling all
over the world while the torretto clan
is based in Los Angeles they seem to
find themselves breaking International
laws consistently fast 10 is no
different this time the street racing
spy thieves find themselves filming in
the United Kingdom Italy and Portugal
specifically the fast 10 team made their
way to Rome where agder Jason Momoa was
seen filming scenes for the movie aside
from their International escapades the
fast 10 team returned to Angelino
Heights to film the majority of the LA
scenes with plenty of car chases and
intense stunts Making Waves across their
usual stomping grounds as variety
reported locals weren't too enthusiastic
about the film's return with some even
organizing protests against the
production ever since the first film was
released in 2001 popular Fast and
Furious filming locations mainly Bob's
Market from the first film have been
desired points of interest for fans and
reckless drivers alike leading to
dangerous incidents on local roads of
course not everyone was obsessed about
the movie being filmed in their
neighborhood homeowner planaria price
made it clear that she didn't want
filming to end telling variety it's one
of the most important economic things we
have in Los Angeles known for its clever
retcons and devil may care attitude the
fast Saga isn't the easiest franchise to
sit down and watch without the proper
contacts some of the earliest films
actually take place later on in the
timeline while later movies serve as
prequels of sorts still the very first
film The Fast and the Furious is where
everyone should start as it introduces
the world and the primary characters
namely even Diesel's Dom Toretto and
Paul Walker's Brian O'Connor after the
original 2001 feature Brian's Adventures
Continue in the sequel Too Fast Too
Furious although Don doesn't reunite
with his friend until 2009's Fast and
Furious which is technically the fourth
film but serves as the third
chronologically from there fast 5 and
Fast and Furious 6 continue the plot
threads established in the fourth film
the third film released in the series
The Fast and the Furious Tokyo Drift
takes place immediately after the sick
film leading into Furious 7 which ties
every previous installment together
while Furious 7 was notable as Walker's
last portrayal of Brian O'Connor before
his untimely death a series continued
with the fate of the Furious tying in
with the main franchise Fast and Furious
presents Hobson Shore takes place after
the fate of the Furious but before F9
fast 10 will directly follow the events
of F9 and begin the end of the Toretto
Clans International adventures together
from the very first fast and furious
Adventure Paul Walker's Brian O'Connor
made his mark on the franchise and
quickly solidified himself as a member
of the terretto family after becoming
best friends of Dom and having children
with his sister Mia that Brian
Carrington was retired following Furious
7 due to Paul Walker's real-life death
both the fate of the Furious and F9
offered explanations for his lack of
involvement still the character remains
a part of The overarching Fast and
Furious story
again when they became parents
we're not them it seems like the fast
Saga can only hold out on showing Brian
again for so long and is becoming
increasingly unlikely that the character
would continue to sit out each and every
new conflict that Tom Letty and the Gang
find themselves involved in Furious 7
sends off Brian well in a respectful
ending that Arnold Walker and the
character but with all the constant
teases and references it's becoming
increasingly less believable that Brian
wouldn't show up again at some point
when speaking with total film Vin Diesel
made it clear that the fast Saga won't
end without a proper send-off for four
Walkers breakout character I will give
you this without spoiling anything I
couldn't imagine this Saga ending
without truly saying goodbye to Brian
O'Connor in almost every Fast and
Furious movie were introduced to a new
villain who has some strange holdover
our favorite found family this has
ranged from International terrorists to
drug lords and assassins with some of
Dom's most hated enemies becoming uneasy
allies later on with fast 10 Jason Momoa
has been added to the ever-growing list
of adversaries but like Furious 7
Nemesis decade Shore before him momoa's
Dante Reyes also has a previous
connection to Dom and his crew as
revealed in the first 10 trailers
Dante's time in the fast Saga extends
back to Fast Five when Dom Brian and
their crew took down drug lord Hanan
Reyes while Momoa obviously didn't show
up in Fast 5 clever Reckoning and
repurposed footage have included him in
the narrative though it was technically
Luke Hobbs who executed Reyes the
makeshift terrato family was ultimately
responsible for the drug Lord's defeat
hoping to enact his revenge against his
father's Killers the moa's character is
rooted within the franchise's mythology
and aims to be the perfect anti-thesis
of Dom as director Lewis letterier
described him to Esquire he's also the a
polar opposite of damn he's all color
and flamboyance it's a yin and yang the
Christ and the Antichrist the anti-darm
one of the strangest additions to the
later years of the first Saga was a
government spymaster Mr Nobody played to
Perfection by Kurt Russell Mr Nobody
first appeared in Furious 7 at the tail
end of Brian O'Connor's tenure in the
series with the advance of this secret
super spy Dom and his family were
ushered into a new world of
international Espionage with potentially
disastrous consequences appearing in
illustri installments Russell's
character isn't slated to appear in fast
turn leaving his fate ambiguous at the
beginning of F9 the fast Saga Mr Nobody
is credited with capturing Cipher and
transporting her by plane back to the US
and surprisingly this transport doesn't
go as planned and Mr nobody's plane goes
down leaving Cypher to join Jacob
Toretto on his revenge Mission Against
Dom in all the chaos the fate of Mr
Nobody is never officially addressed
though Han eventually explains how the
agent helped him fake his death his
career whereabouts remain unclear
although Russell is not returning for
fast 10 at least as far as we know Mr
nobody's daughter Tess is set to appear
played by Brie Larson the trailer
suggests that tests will Aid Dom and his
team in their mission against Dante
Reyes acting in a similar capacity as
her father did when working with the
team
ever since Fast Five Dwayne Johnson has
been an iconic part of The Fast and
Furious franchise though his involvement
has not been without some controversy
series starving diesel had initially
fought for Johnson's casting as
Government Bounty Hunter Luke Hobbs in
the fifth film but the two clashed on
set Jon Snow prized his role in Fast and
Furious 6 and Furious 7. but took a
break during the eighth installment
instead developing his own spin-off with
Jason Statham and Fast and Furious
presents Hobbs and Shore when it comes
to the fate of the world it becomes my
business Johnson also skipped F9 the
fast Saga though his spin-off co-star
reprise his role ashore for an
uncredited after credit sequence while
Statham is set to return ashore once
more for fast 10 Hobbs will not be
joining him since Johnson's character
was so important to Fast Five he
executed Hanan Reyes after all it will
be interesting to see how fast 10 deals
as hobb's absence and if Dante rails
will even attempt to assassinate Hobbes
as well while Dwayne Johnson has
repeatedly distanced himself from the
fast Saga fans still hope to see Luke
Hobbs once more before the franchise
closed results with no concrete news on
a potential Hobson's short Sequel and
Johnson's disinterest in returning to
the main series it's probably a safe bet
to assume that hobbs's story will come
to a close off screen it's not ideal but
that's Show Business
Fast and Furious fans are also eager to
see gal gadot's Gisele return first
appearing in the fourth installment Fast
and Furious Giselle joins Dom's crew as
a weapons expert and specialist as a
former CIA agent she was an enormous
asset to the team in both Fast Five and
Fast and Furious 6. sadly Giselle met
her end saving her boyfriend Han near
the tail end of the sixth movie and many
fans still aren't over it
Giselle
aside from some passing mentions and the
deleted scene from Furious 7 the dirt
has been too busy playing Wonder Woman
in the DC EU to return full time to the
franchise after Han's death in Tokyo
Drift and subsequent return in F9 which
followed letty's death and Resurrection
a few films prior is as possible as ever
that giselle's demise could have been
faked also especially given her ties to
Mr Nobody well there hasn't been any
official confirmation regarding
giselle's return to the fast Saga the
director reported that galga dirt to the
film scenes for fast 10. in response to
questions regarding giselle's possible
Resurrection on actor Sun Kang told
Digital Spy that there was no reason the
two couldn't be reunited by the
franchise's end why can't she who
doesn't want a load of galga does in
their life if she does return odds are
good that her Survivor will be revealed
in a post-credits sequence on March 10th
with just over two months until the film
was set to hit theaters Vin Diesel
filmed a short scene characterized as a
tag or button although fans might just
call a post-credits scene he may have
filmed it with a co-star whose identity
wasn't confirmed or
be his alleged secret scene partner
it seems that with almost every new
Venture into the fast Saga the movies
get bigger and increasingly more
expensive following the success of the
fifth and sixth films Furious 7 was
given a larger budget that after the
death of Paul Walker quickly grew to 250
million dollars for digital Recreations
and reshoes the following film the fate
of the Furious was granted a similar
budget while the next two franchise
installments Hobson Shore and F9 cost
200 million dollars each these budgets
were a far cry from the original film's
budget of 38 million dollars that's the
first part of a greater franchise finale
the rap reported that the new film's
budget is pushing 340 million dollars
making it one of the most expensive
films ever made in comparison Avengers
end game had a budget of 356 million
dollars and the budget for James
Cameron's Avatar the way of water was
reported to be somewhere around 350
million dollars though fast 10 is less
expensive than those two it's still more
costly than popular Blockbusters
including Avengers Infinity war or
Pirates of the Caribbean at World's End
exact numbers aside the point is that
fasten will be huge and while a big
budget does not necessarily equal a hit
we can hope that the extra cash will be
used wisely to bring the story to life
if one thing is obvious about the Fast
and the Furious and there's many sequels
is that every new addition gets just a
bit bigger and even harder to believe a
film that was originally about illegal
racing stolen DVD players and one cop's
infiltration of a street gang quickly
shifted genres and became something
bigger than anyone had previously
thought possible in the sequel Brian
goes undercover to take down a drug
kingpin in the Fast and the Furious
Tokyo Drift Everything Changes focusing
on set on American Sean Boswell in Tokyo
as he falls into street racing from the
fourth film on the franchise found its
voice as an adrenaline fueled car
Centric Heist series but it evolved into
something even bigger from there too
I don't have friends
I got family the franchise since has
turned into a globetrotting action
series with ties to the Spy genre with
each film becoming increasingly
unrealistic as the series pressed onward
however that's not what fast X director
Lewis letterier hopes to do with the
10th installment the director told
Esquire when discussing his vision for
the film what I wanted to do on this one
because it's very much my style was to
ground it more in reality I wanted it to
feel like fast one fast three and Fast
Five movies that feel grounded whether
that actually translates to the big
screen remains to be seen But audiences
will get a chance to see for themselves
when fast 10 comes roaring into theaters
on May 19th